no I'm so down to see the minions in
Jude I selnick like that way I saw a
movie okay all right
Who am I very nice huh
odd Homer Simpson don't hug it I love it
it is it is very nice Oh Marty McFly
from Back to the Future I can't dude
I can't really I don't know I don't know
is this so funny
he's funny to me I love is delivery it's
so true I'm sorry Homer Simpson's doll
holy [ __ ] this whoa oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
saw my shadow is in the shot is it yeah
you didn't say I didn't see it at first
Homer Simpson don't
Homer Simpson right dough was that good
that's not a good one we weren't
supposed to slow me in yeah you heard
supposed to throw them in you're
supposed to like fake a knowing of it my
phone in my pocket
dude I'm sorry I'm mark I'm sorry I'm
sorry
no stop James stop I'm sorry one stop -
I didn't get it I didn't get that I
swallowed so much water you didn't get
that no well you want to go on now I'm
good we could do another take with you
oh it's fine it's fine are you sure yeah
you want to the Homer Simpson part no no
no mark mark right we both mark mark
iein mark no seriously what the hell
seriously it's okay Ryan right come hard
right mark Ryan I have no Ryan
no right Marcus nice [ __ ] you weren't
recording huh are you kidding not even
joking
no according now would I pause that
you're Homer Simpson dog
did you hit him okay [ __ ] I really did
hit him oh [ __ ]
Oh get him get him no one dude get him I
guess